as more contouring movies are added to
the franchise keeping track of things
can get confusing especially since they
jump around chronologically luckily we
figured out when everything takes place
from freaky nuns to haunted houses
here's the entire conjuring universe
story explained chronologically speaking
the conjuring universe all starts with
the nun the film takes place in 1952 in
the abbey of st. carta in Romania where
father Burke and the novitiate sister
Irene are investigating the death of one
of the abbeys nuns they discover the
nuns have been spending most of their
time praying in shifts to keep a nun
shaped evil entity from hitchhiking its
way out into the real world on a human
host as it turns out the abbey was
originally built by a Duke during the
Middle Ages who was more interested in
demon worship than Catholicism he
managed to raise the demon Balor but was
stopped by a group of Christian Knights
who were able to seal VALIC for a while
with the help of a local man named
Frenchie father Burke and sister Irene
seemed to finally banish violet back to
hell but as it happens
Valek manages to hitch a supernatural
ride out of town on friend she's back
the story of Annabelle starts in 1943
with Annabelle creation when the doll
maker named Samuel Mullins and his wife
Astor lose their seven-year-old daughter
Annabelle in a freak car accident about
12 years later the Mullins opened the
doors to a group of orphaned girls and
the nun tasked with their care when one
of the orphans stumbles upon a porcelain
doll in a locked bedroom she unwittingly
releases a demon that wreaks havoc on
the house and its inhabitants it soon
revealed that the Mullins had been
tricked into letting a demon take
possession of one of Samuels dolls and
it's now decided to try and find a human
host by the end of the ordeal the demon
has succeeded in possessing the unlucky
orphan who escapes and now going by the
name Annabelle winds up being adopted by
a nice family in Santa Monica there she
grows up runs away joins a cult and then
returns to murder her adoptive parents
as it turns out the poor adopted parents
of Annabelle lived next door to John and
Mia form the main protagonists of 2014's
Annabelle John has given his wife Mia an
antique porcelain doll as a gift for
their unborn child
but after Annabelle and her boyfriend
kill her parents they move on to the
form residence where Annabelle
immediately takes liking to Mia's
antique doll when the human Annabelle
dies the demon hops into the doll terror
sets in as the newly demonic doll
decides to torment the form families
willing to trade her own soul to save
her newborn daughter Mia tries to jump
out of her window with the doll luckily
John and Mia's friend Evelyn arrive in
time to stop her and Evelyn sacrifices
herself to save the family in the end an
unsuspecting woman buys the doll from a
toy shop as a gift for her daughter a
nurse in the conjuring we revisit that
nurse who is now at the mercy of the
demon spirit trapped inside the toy so
the Warrens take the doll off the nurses
hands and move on to their next case
in 1971 the Warrens are teaching a class
on demonology at Massachusetts Western
University during the lecture they play
footage of a possessed man named Maurice
who EDD explains killed himself after
attempting to shoot his wife Maurice is
Frenchie the nice guy who spent some
time in Romania in the 50s came home
with a demon nun as a souvenir one of
the attendees at the Warrens demonology
lecture is Carolyn Perron whose family
has recently moved into a Rhode Island
farmhouse unfortunately they're now
being tormented by a malevolent clap
happy spirit after some digging the
Warrens discover the house was built on
land that once belonged to a witch named
Bathsheba
unfortunately that discovery comes a
little late
bathsheba has already set her sights on
carolyn and the now possessed mother
brings her kids back to the house to
kill them the Warrens show up just in
time and the curse of bathsheba is
lifted finally leaving the parens with a
livable farmhouse
when ed and Lorraine Warren are needed
on an overnight investigation they hire
a girl named Mary Ellen to stay over and
keep an eye on their daughter Judy
unfortunally Mary Ellen's friend Daniela
drops by the house uninvited she finds a
way into the Warrens artifact room
disturbs Annabelle and unleashes every
ghost and demon the Warren's have
trapped in their basement
the girls spend the night essentially
playing hide and seek with a bunch of
possessed objects before Annabelle has
returned to her case once and for all
in 1973 Anna tape Garcia is a social
worker who gets mixed up with La Llorona
when she takes the sons of a woman named
Patrice Alvarez to the police
unwittingly allowing the titular spirit
access to kill them as a result
Anna's own children are targeted by the
spirit so Anna seeks help from father
Perez the priest from Annabelle who
obviously has some experience with evil
beings he tells her about a former
priest named Raphael alvera who can
banish the entity one banished spirit
later and Anna and her children are safe
although she keeps the necklace that
once belonged to the wailing woman in a
deleted scene it's revealed that she
hands the necklace over to Rafael what
do under this
I know of a couple on these coasts who
look after things like this Valek makes
his return in 1976 during the conjuring
to the film that sees Edie and Lorraine
Warren seemingly defeat the spirit for
good beginning in 1976 the war ends are
investigating the infamous Amityville
murders and Lorraine has a vision where
she comes face to face with phallic and
a vision of her husband's death
Lorraine continues to see visions of the
demon nun even as the pair traveled in
field England where the Hodgson family
has been experiencing paranormal
activity when it appears as though the
entire haunting is a hoax put on by the
family to gain Fame the Warren's pack up
their things to leave but Lorraine soon
realizes that VALIC has been behind the
entire thing and they return to the
house in a last-ditch effort to save the
family and almost falls to his death in
the process leaving Lorraine to go
head-to-head with valla herself she
succeeds in banishing the demon by using
its name and pulls Edie to safety
the day is saved and everything seems to
be going smoothly at least until the
next film and the franchisee gets
released check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]